attendez la terre vous avez tous déjà vu
cette photographie au moins sur la
couverture de vos livres d'histoire géo
et certainement bien ailleurs parce que
cette photo c'est la photo la plus
reproduites de l'histoire de l'humanité
pourquoi c'est la seule qu'on est elle
est unique c'est le seul portrait que
l'on ait de la terre tout éclairé ça
c'était jusqu'à l'année dernière
l'histoire de cette photo est moins
connu elle s'appelle blue marble elle a
été prise le 7 décembre 1972 par les
astronautes de la mission apollo 17
cette mission apollo 17 était la
dernière des missions apollo et dans
toutes les missions précédentes la terre
n'était jamais complètement éclairé donc
c'était la première photo de la terre
qu'on a reçus mais aussi la dernière
cette photo quand on l'a reçu elle a
tout changé pour la première fois
l'humanité
voyez sa maison elle découvrait que la
terre était ronde
on le savait on nous l'avait dit on en
avait la preuve cette photo nous a fait
aussi comprendre que notre plat tête
était magnifique mais qu'elle était
aussi fragile
perdu dans une ante et n'étant du noir
et le cube elle nous a donné envie de
nous la protéger
cette photo a démarré un mouvement qu'on
appelle la conscience planétaire
elle est intervenue en 1972 exactement
quand les problèmes environnementaux
devenez globaux et elle a aidé le
développement des mouvements écologistes
malheureusement l'effet de cette photo
s'est estompée avec les décennies
mon histoire avec la terre démarre il ya
exactement 20 ans en 1996 un ami d'école
d'ingénieurs qui faisait son stage à
l'aérospatiale m'offre un livre qui a
changé ma vie je n'imaginais pas du tout
à l'époque à quel point il allait
m'emmener aussi loin ce livre il
s'appelle clair de terre il a été édité
par l'association des explorateurs de
l'espace
c'est un nom un peu pompeux
en gros désigné l'amicale des anciens
astronautes ce livre je les feuilletés
j'ai vu des photos absolument à couper
le souffle de la terre prises depuis
l'espace
mais c'est pas tellement ça qui m'a
intrigué c'étaient les textes qui était
à côté de ces photos c'était des six
stations d'astronautes d'une poésie
extraordinaire semblait avoir été touché
par la grâce
mais surtout pour d'un amour que je
n'avais jamais vu pour la terre je me
disais qu'il y avait là peut-être
quelque chose à exploiter pour changer
les choses et rendre le monde meilleur
eugene cernan qui était le dernier homme
à marcher sur la lune a par exemple
écrit dans ce livre nous étions partis
pour découvrir la lune
nous avons découvert la terre le sultan
al saoud qui fait partie de la famille
d'arabie saoudite famille royale qui a
séjourné à bord de la station spatiale
internationale a eu ces mots lui aussi
magnifique
le premier jour nous montrions notre
pays au troisième jour notre continent à
partir du cinquième jour nous ne faisons
plus attention qu'à la seule terre et se
livre pendant des dizaines et des
dizaines de citations on voit les
astronautes des hommes des femmes de
tous les âges de toutes les sexualités
avec cet amour incommensurable pour la
terre quelque chose semble les avoir
touchés cet effet a été étudié et porte
le nom de rvr view effect il a été
montré scientifiquement que l'effet
combiné de la pesanteur de la peur du
silence et de l'exposition grand large à
la terre vue depuis l'espace qui tourne
avec un rythme lancinant créé toutes les
conditions pour une expérience mystique
extatique qui les a marqués à vie
ces astronautes étaient persuadés que la
terre était un être vivant
interconnectés et qu'il fallait
absolument la préserver le seul problème
c'est qu'il y avait que 500 personnes
qui avaient vécu cette transformation
il fallait généraliser ça heureusement
un homme a eu un rêve
cet homme c'est le vice président al
gore en février 98
ils se demandaient comment associer les
gens autour du défi sur le dérèglement
climatique
c'était deux mois après les négociations
du protocole de kyoto où il s'était
beaucoup investi en tant que vice
président des états unis
une nuit inspiré par blue marble et ce
qu'elle avait changé quand il était plus
jeune il eut le rêve d'envoyer une sonde
dans l'espace pour filmer en temps réel
et diffusée sur internet qui venait de
naître ces images pour tous les gens
pour qu'ils puissent toujours voir le
village le visage éclairé de gaia
l'avantagent quand on est vice président
des états unis c'est qu'on peut lancer
un challenge à la nasa
donc après en avoir parlé avec quelques
spécialistes pour s'assurer que c'était
pas complètement idiot le bureau du
vice-président par un communiqué de
presse a lancé le défi à la nasa
d'envoyer un satellite dans l'espace
pour amener ces images et si possible
avant la fin de l'année 2000 au début du
troisième millénaire
donc en gros il avait deux ans le
problème c'est que pour avoir ces images
c'est très compliqué parce que si vous
voulez avoir en temps réel toujours des
images de la terre complètement éclairé
il faut être situé sur l'axé terre
soleil puisque c'est le seul axe où la
terre est toujours éclairés si vous êtes
trop près du soleil la force
d'attraction du soleil vous happe tir si
vous êtes trop près de la terre c'est
celle de la de la terre qui vous attirez
ya qu un seul point entre les deux qui
s'appelle le point de lagrange et l'un
ou les deux forces annuler manque de pot
il à 1.5 million de kilomètres de la
terre
la nasa a relevé le défi en un temps
record ils ont bâti ce satellite qui
s'appelle triana qui était fin prêt pour
regagner ce point l1 avant la fin du
millénaire triana c'était le nom d'un
des amis enfin des compatriotes de
christophe colomb qui était au bord de
la mort de la pizza en haut du mât et
qui premier a vu le nouveau
monde donc al gore avait donné lui-même
le nouveau satellite il avait appelé
triana à l'époque j'étais chercheur en
mathématiques aux états unis j'étais
tellement fascinée par ce projet que
j'étais prêt à lâcher mon boulot et
aller m'occuper travaillé à la nasa pour
la promotion de ces images parce que je
me disais qu'il y avait là quelque chose
d'extraordinaire mais les choses se sont
gâtées
les choses se sont gâtées quand al gore
a eu la mauvaise idée de vouloir occuper
la maison blanche face à george bush
avant déjà la fin sa défaite et
républicains qui tenait le congrès ont
tout fait pour limiter faut ralentir
cette mission pour pas qu'ils puissent
partir au niveau de l'année 2000 ça ce
n'était pas le plus grave
une des premières missions que george
bush et dick cheney ont prises quand ils
ont eu leur investiture en 2001 fut
d'arrêter complètement la mission triana
c'était unique dans l'histoire de la
nasa la mission était construite à était
prête à partir et c'était juste pour
faire payer al gore à la fois d'avoir
été un très bon opposants à la
candidature est aussi le protocole de
kyoto sur lequel il s'était investi
quand j'ai vu ça pour moi un rêve
s'était brisé je comprenais pas qu'on
pouvait avoir une vision aussi cynique
du monde et je suis passé par un peu
tous les états premières et à la
tristesse deuxième et à la rage
et puis je suis revenu à cette notion
d'émerveillement et je le disais c'est
pas possible il faut que ces images
existent comme j'étais pas vice
président des états unis j'avais pas de
capacité à lancer contre mission j'étais
mathématicien je me suis dit je vais
dans le cadre d'un roman faire ressentir
à mes lecteurs ce qu'est lover view
effect et ça m'a pris dix ans j'ai écrit
deux romans qui raconte le changement de
conscience et la révolution qui
s'opérait c6 et si ces images existent
et le rêve continue
au moins dans ma tête et dans celle de
mes lecteurs en 2013 miracle j'étais en
train d'écrire un article sur lover view
est fake
quand en faisant des recherches j'ai
découvert que l'administration obama
avait secrètement décidé de relancer la
mission d'al
il avait pris des précautions énorme
première chose ils ont changé le nom de
la mission ne s'appelait plus triana
mais discover deuxième chose ils ont
changé l'objet de la mission
ce n'était plus de filmer la terre mais
de filmer le soleil qui est très bien
visible aussi du point dans le but de
prévenir la terre en cas d'éruptions
solaires qui peuvent détruire nos
équipements électromagnétiques autour de
ce projet ils ont embarqué d'autres
agences donc il y avait la nasa us air
force qui a beaucoup de d'équipement en
orbite est aussi lannoy qui est
l'institution météorologiques
américaines pour un peut rajouter du
piment à tout ça la nasa a décidé de me
confier le lancement à une firme privée
une jeune start-up space x d'elon musk
mais j'avais confiance dans le
visionnaire elon musk pour mener cette
mission à vous ça c'est en 2013
pendant deux ans j'ai encore pas dormir
pour en attendant que cette mission
parts
le lancement a été reporté trois fois
mais en février 2015
elle est partie elle est partie elle a
pris son envol vers ce point l 1 à 1.5
million de kilomètres ça à peu près
quatre fois la distance terre-lune
il est arrivé là bas au mois de juin de
l'année dernière juin 2015 et
j'attendais ces premières photos et puis
surtout ces images qu al gore nous avait
promis et qui déclencherait chez tout le
monde lover viau effect il a fallu
encore attendre un mois et le 21 juillet
2015 le second portrait de gaia nous a
été révélé par par la nasa
le voici voyez que ce n'est pas la même
photo de la terre puisque vous n'avez
plus l'afrique au premier plan comme on
le voit toujours sur cette photo vous
marble ici ces centres est évidemment
sur les états unis
et je puis mais dans le communiqué de la
nasa
je m'attendais à trouver le lien vers la
fameuse vidéo temps réel aucun lien vers
la fameuse vidéo temps réel et mais
promettait un site web au mois de
septembre donc à nouveau deux mois
d'attentes septembre 2015 la nasa
respecte ses engagements et publie son
fameux site web dans lequel il n'y avait
pas de vidéo mais uniquement des photos
entre 10 et 20 photos par jour
pris sous différents angles de la terre
quand elle tournait personne n'a parlé
de ces photos personne ne les a utilisés
aucun overview effect n'a été déclenchée
et un grand désarroi m'a habité tout ça
pour ça et puis j'ai eu un déclic après
les attentats de paris en novembre 2015
quand j'ai vu toute cette noirceur je me
suis dit il ya vraiment besoin de poésie
dans ce monde et je n'avais pas le
courage ou le temps de m'occuper tout
seul de ces images de la nasa
donc j'ai envoyé un message à mes
lecteurs en disant qu est-ce qui veut
m'aider à faire quelque chose avec ces
images
et là miracle mon ami michael boccara
qui est maintenant en israël qu ici ce
soir m'a contacté et m'a dit écoute
c'est lui qui m'avait passé ce livre
clair de thé m a dit je veut bien
t'aider
on avait commencé cette histoire
ensemble on allait à finir ensemble on a
passé nos nuits à essayer de voir ce
qu'est ce que l'on pourrait faire avec
ces images
et puis un soir eurêka
séduction disposer de plusieurs images
de la terre prises sous différents
angles et qu'on les projeter sur une
sphère en les interpellant on devrait
pouvoir recréer cette fameuse vidéo
manquantes nar passé un certain nombre
de nuits malheur de nos femmes
toujours sur internet entre la france et
israël
et un soir on a vu la terre tournait
pour la première fois devant nos yeux il
était très tard on s'est appelés ont été
émerveillés et ce soir vous allez vous
aussi voir ces images
ces images ont été pris juste avant la
préparation de la delà de la conférence
donc ces images du 29 mai elles sont
prises du point l1 donc imaginez vous
dans ce point
admirez la terre si c'est possible de
l'éteindre complètement la lumière et je
voulais c'est faire l'expérience de la
terre
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là après
avoir réalisé cette première vidéo on a
décidé de tester un peu la réaction des
gens et on l'a mis sur internet sur
instagram et on a tagué la nasa quelques
heures après nous recevions un mail de
la nasa qui nous féliciter qui se
demandait comment on avait pu réaliser
cette vidéo je crois que ça a été un des
moments les plus forts où on a été donc
en communication avec le responsable de
la mission discover et plus
particulièrement de la caméra qui
filmait la terre à lui poser un milliard
de questions et lui aussi de comprendre
comment on avait réussi ces images et
après cette conversation avec la nasa on
s'est dit mais peut-être là on a réalisé
quelque chose d'important et on s'est
dit on va aller jusqu'au bout de notre
rêve
ce rêve c'est que ces images on se les
approprient tous pour vraiment avoir ce
sentiment de ce bien commun collectif
qu'on doit préserver et pour pouvoir
s'est approprié tous il faut pouvoir les
diffuser sur tout type d'écran et des
écrans ne manquent pas on pourrait les
projeter sur des gratte ciel mais aussi
dans la paume de nos mains sur des
téléphones portables et donc on a créé
un projet qui s'appelle blue turn le
tournant bleus et sur le site www en
power vous vous retrouvez gratuitement
toutes ces images toutes ces vidéos et
on va rajouter cet été une appli qui
vous permettra sur des tablettes ou sur
des téléphones de pouvoir gratuitement
consulter et de voir toujours les
dernières images de la terre et donc de
réaliser ce rêve d'al gore qu'était
devenu le nôtre avec ces images
avec ces images on espère générer un
nouvel enthousiasme autour de cette
planète et surtout des projets
artistiques méditatif éducatif inédit on
espère que ces projets pourront plonger
chacun de nous dans cette overview
effect et nous amener au prochain niveau
de conscience planétaire
quand les astronautes d'apollo 17
avaient pris cette photo il ne savait
pas du tout ce qui allait se produire
nous non plus on sait pas du tout ce qui
va se produire
ces images sont les vôtres à vous de
jouer merci